was no one stopping women from going to
those fields
they just don't choose those fields and
where and where are the marches about
the equality of workplace deaths men do
most of the hard jobs plumbing
electricity all of the jobs where you
you can die on the job more men do it
and so they're the majority of suicides
they're the majority of workplace deaths
but no one cares because they see men as
expendable all they care about is the
one percent jobs like do you want to be
a fireman like do women generally want
to run into burning buildings and help
people no but do they want to help
people a different way women will come
become midwives
but it's interesting because even in
this conversation like when we talk
about inequality it's always about the
women and no one cares about the man
yeah so what did jordan peterson say
over 90 percent of bricklayers are men
why are we not looking for equality in
bricklaying oh my god there's too many
men in bricklaying girls you need to
start when you start getting the female
quarters in women don't want to lay
bricks